[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
i'm fraser nelson on this week's show we
ask if a housing ladder has become a
trap we look at the growing
political rebellion against boris
johnson's reforms
we also look at the notion of white
privilege and whether that can be
reconciled
with the performance of the white
working class in the education system
we look at the manchester bombing
inquiry douglas murray
asks what that's thrown up and finally
we look at hogarth his legacy
and the great political satirists we
speak to michael heath
the spectators cartoon editor about his
life and his art
first our cover story this week is about
the scandal of new build houses
boris johnson wants his mps to vote
through planning reforms
but the rebellion is stretching far
beyond westminster
owning a home used to be a dream but for
millions
it's now a nightmare due to the dismal
quality of homes
and the crippling cost of repairing them
i'm joined now by james forsyth and
katie balls so james tell us about this
parliamentary housing rebellion
i think tory mps think that this these
measures will not be popular in their
constituencies
that sense has been massively heightened
by the cheshire amisham
by-election mother the dems campaign
very heavily in opposition to the
government's proposed planning reforms
and when you see a seat with a sixteen
thousand tory majority end of an eight
thousand live dead majority that's more
more votes than the dems got in total in
that seat in 2017
you see lots of tory mps begin to get
nervous and it's worth remembering that
this policy
wasn't popular on the tory benches in
the first place you know
if you think back to last year there was
a housing algorithm that was meant to
work out
essentially to say right the most houses
should be built
where houses are least affordable that
meant lots of houses being built
in the south east a tory rebellion
forced huge tweaks
uh to that algorithm and we haven't yet
seen the bill and i think the one thing
the whips are trying to say to mps is
look look you know
one of the things that have done went
very hard on the vial election was the
idea but under the
this proposals there would be some uh
develop
individual developments that residents
wouldn't be able to object to i think
there will be some movement on that
before we see the bill but i mean the
tory party is caught in a real bind here
because uh with its existing
uh southern uh electoral base the the
idea of more houses in their
constituencies is not particularly
popular
but if they don't build more houses they
risk seeing
uh what's happened to them in london
where the shift
against home ownership has cost the
tories dearly happening in other places
in the southeast
now casey boris johnson's got a pretty
big majority of 78
could he really have lost control of
parliament already could he really be in
a situation
where he cannot get his signature
planning reforms through parliament
because his party is prepared to
overturn that size of a majority
i think when it comes to reform and
driving change boris johnson so far
is actually not in a great situation
because we have had quite a few
rebellions
and i think on planning reform many mps
in the south think that ultimately the
reforms are dead
now cabinet ministers disagree there's
some who
arguing privately actually what the
government needs to do is double down on
this
you know these southern mps don't know
what's good for them if
you don't build more homes if you don't
do something drastic
you're not going to have tory voters in
about 10 15 years time
and but i think anyone who can do you
know basic arithmetic
is starting to see the problem in this
and i think the issue for boris johnson
is that
once you know an mp rebels they often do
it again and you can start to see on a
range of issues so we just had the
foreign aid rebellion that didn't quite
get to be a rebellion in terms of the
floor of the commons
and because there was not a vote in the
end but the government looked on course
to lose it
and i think that one of the issues with
boris johnson when it comes to trying to
talk around these people should they
press ahead
uh with drastic planning reforms is that
uh well
a people are very worried about losing
their seats in the next election and
that as james says that's from the
by-election
but b there are a lot of mps in
traditional tour receipts who don't have
much time for boris johnson
they don't think boris johnson has
treated them with respect and i think
that boris johnson
when theresa may was prime minister
didn't really listen to the whip
so why should they now james we know
what boris johnson personally thinks
about this he thinks as you were
saying that more house owners means more
tory voters and that these southern tory
nimbys are basically
writing their own political funeral
wishes because nobody's going to vote
for them
if people can't get houses so can we see
here
almost a sort of um i wouldn't call it
ideology but certain the political
principles here the kind of what shirley
lewin
argued are the vigorous virtues of
homeownership as soon as you
let somebody buy a house that person
becomes a tory voter
is is that how you think the argument is
cena number 10
yeah look the tory party is the party of
the property owning democracy
and if in these seats you get fewer
homeowners and more renters
they will become less safe the problem
you've got is
is the transition period essentially
which is uh
the initial uh initially approving the
building of more houses
is not necessarily popular in these
places lots of uh
these people moved out out because they
wanted to live someone which they felt
was quite
rural and if you end up with lots more
houses being built people will feel that
that sense is being taken away from them
you know and an englishman's home is his
castle and all that and so i think you
run into those
problems i think the the trick the
problem is other issue for number 10 now
is
planning is so up in lights but they
they could there is a danger you end up
in the worst of all worlds
which is you have to make concessions to
get the bill through so the bill doesn't
do that much
but then every um extra house or every
unpopular development is blamed on these
reforms even
even if it could have passed beforehand
so but i do think this
housing problem is something that you
need to find a way to solve
um because you you clearly need
more houses where people want to live
now i'd like to bring in
my colleague emma byrne she's assistant
editor of a spectator
recently a home owner um emma you bought
a new build and as james says an english
woman's home is her castle
has that been your experience um very
much not so
um i am a victim of the cladding scandal
i bought my one bed flat in east london
under a government-backed shared
ownership scheme
in 2016. last year
i found out that due to retrospective
changes and also after tests
very shoddy building work that my home
will need major um
works to bring it up to scratch and that
because the way that leasehold law works
essentially i will be footing the bill
which could run into tens and tens of
thousands of pounds
uh money which i don't have right so
we're talking here a bill of what could
be i don't know 40 or 50 grand
of that kind of size yeah the the
government has been collecting very few
data and the bills are only starting to
land
but um the sunday times had a piece out
on sunday which showed that the average
bill in the high rise which i'm in which
is over 18 meters
is roughly uh 40 to 50 000
with uh the average uh that's per flat
for the remediation will cost
right it's about five million a building
and how many people are affected by this
are you a freak case no not at all um
so ews one which is uh the buildings
need to be checked to get the special
form it could be up to three million
people
three million people could be stunned
basically for bills
huge bills i mean you say the average is
50 grand a high rise
what simply because robert generic
decided to change regulations and saddle
and people like you with a bill but why
couldn't you go back to the
hope the people you bought the house
from and say look you saw me building
that was not fit for purpose
it's time for you to to foot the bill
not me
well the three million people at ews one
the affected leaseholders is around 750
000
to 1.5 million i think it is who could
face extraordinary bills
um essentially the way that leasehold
work law works
um freeholders can just pass these costs
on with very little legal protection
also i'm in a new build so i have vague
legal protections under
the defective premises act and also i've
still got my warranty in place
but again there's absolutely no
guarantee um because of these
retrospective changes
that um i can bring a claim against any
of this
and uh for people who are in buildings
that are older it's essentially up to
the whim of the freeholder and developer
who are increasingly proving themselves
quite bad players
right so you can see the political
problem here i mean according to classic
political theory you should be an
aspiring tory voter given that you're
you're a homeowner um but would you
describe yourself as
an aspiring tory voter now um
i mean absolutely not uh this has
revolutionized me and certainly a
generation of homeowners
against this government who are seem to
be either not understanding the scale of
what's coming
which is going to be mass repossessions
quite frankly because no one can pay
these bills especially as a lot of
people are first-time buyers
um or more cynically that we're
collateral damage to protect
the industry i'd like to bring in
another colleague now kate andrews khu
renting
you'd like to to buy a house what do you
think about this
well i've been lucky enough to share a
uh
covered bubble with emma in the office
this year
and um it's been horrible to watch what
she's gone through but frankly i've i've
learned
a lot from her um and i wouldn't touch
a new build now um you know i think
there's been
failures across the board here the
builders have taken advantage of the
situation
the government's very restrictive
planning system
um has made it uh very difficult for
little guys to get in and to build more
homes
and so you know i think there are
multiple problems going on here
um but i i am looking to to buy for the
first time i'm very hopeful i'll be able
to do so in the near future
i had one of the mainstream estate
agents call me the other day
and they said oh we have this property
we'd like for you to look at it and i
said
oh it looks like it's a new build and
they said yeah you get more space it's
brand new and i said oh no sorry i'm
i'm not interested keeping emma's story
in the back of my mind
they really pushed me they said oh if
you're worried about cladding
don't worry about that you know this
building is completely up to scratch
it's brand new
and i pushed back i said you know now
that the government is willing to
retrospectively change the law
on these building materials on cladding
it's just not an investment i think i
want to make
and the guy paused on the phone he
laughed and he said
wow you really know your stuff yeah i
wouldn't touch them either
my goodness so the estate agents and
somebody in the business of selling
houses
basically knew but they had dodgy
products on their books
and they even he thought but the risk of
being stung with the bill
wasn't worth it this is a stitch up on
every level
houses are being built and sold to
people and there is widespread awareness
that they're just not up to scratch
so i'm very thankful for emma uh for
sharing her story with
so many of us and she's been doing
really great work highlighting the issue
of the clouding scandal here at the
spectator but
also on on lots of other platforms
because first and foremost this issue
needs to be raised for people like emma
who are so badly affected by it and who
are getting these huge bills through the
mail
but it's important for people like me
too those of us who are
hopeful first-time buyers who could be
walking into a huge
trap and as i said before this is
happening at every level from the
builders
to the government even to the estate
agents everybody knows there's a problem
but it's a very expensive one to fix and
nobody wants to foot the bill so
poor emma's told that she's gonna have
to pay for it james forsyth can i bring
you back in here you've written quite a
lot about how tour emps need to accept
the need to build more houses if they
don't do it they'll be considering
themselves to
political history but do you think the
prime minister's taking in
like the stories of people like um of
kate and emma
here that this that sort of houses
they're realistically on the horizon
are houses that a lot of young people
don't want to touch because they
basically think that they
they cannot afford the sort of damocles
hanging over them the massive bills they
might get if they buy
shoddy houses and rightly or wrongly
we're just getting out that if you buy a
new build
you're gonna be in for some pretty
unpleasant surprises in a few years time
i think one of the points that liam
halligan makes so powerfully in his
cover story for this week's spectator
is that the housing industry in this
country is essentially an oligopoly
it's dominated by five or six big
developers
and uh that is an unhealthy market i
think one of the arguments in favor of
planning reform
is that by simplifying the process it
would make it
easier for small builders to uh to do
developments because there would be less
legal work involved in the planning
process i personally think that you need
to go further than that i think you need
the government to directly commission
small builders to inject more
competition into the housing market
james katie and emma thanks very much
indeed now
kate andrews also has a very good story
in the magazine this week
about the extents of the kind of
privileges being enjoyed not just by the
uefa officials who are flying into
london quarantine free to watch the
football final
but the way in which several government
members have been availing themselves of
loopholes not
open to the rest of us over the last few
weeks
and months so kate tell us what you've
uncovered well if you look at the
lifestyles of some people and the
highest levels of government
and as we're seeing this week with the
football other members of the so-called
elite
and the rest of us who have had to obey
these coveted rules
you're seeing a real stark contrast in
in behavior
now this isn't about rule breaking it's
not about breaking the law
it's the fact that ministers design
these covert rules
and so they know exactly where they can
bend them and where the loopholes are
in the first lockdown there were a lot
of political casualties you saw
resignations you saw quite a famous rose
garden press conference
to defend behavior from people who were
thought to be bending the rules
as they saw fit but this time around in
the second and third lockdown there was
more
leeway but of course the public isn't
made aware of that leeway so you have
some pretty egregious examples of say
michael goth flying back from the
champions league final in portugal
getting pinged by test and trace and not
quarantining and he's not quarantining
because there's a scheme
which you can go on which allows you to
test daily wait wait first of all
there's a scheme that gets you out of
quarantine if you're
if you're pinged i'm not sure many
people know about this scheme
how do you apply yeah i suspect a lot of
our viewers won't be familiar with it
and that's because
it's not very clear how you sign up to
this scheme i've been on the
government's web page and there's no
click here and apply button there's an
email address at the very bottom to get
a bit more information but it's not even
clear
that that would sign you up to the
scheme but it does exist
michael gove certainly knows about it
you know he's been at the center of all
these discussions and all of these
systems
so he's on the scheme but there are
plenty of people out there you know
normal worker who's reliant on an hourly
wage who would love to be on that scheme
and yet has been sitting at home for
eight nine ten days depending on when
they get pinged
doing what they think they're supposed
to do abiding by the rules
okay so okay can you just say how many
how many other people are on this scheme
are we we know michael gove's on it but
is it i don't know are there
the hundreds are there thousands how
many people right now are
living in their system where you are not
at risk from being pinged i mean i know
a colleague by a colleague of mine ours
at lara she's having a christening on
saturday she's terrified about being
pinged in case of christening has called
off
katie bowles she's getting married in a
couple of weeks she's
terrified about being pinged before her
wedding she'd have to cancel that so
um how many people are not living under
this sort of um
the threat of being interned by nhs test
and trace
well we're told that thousands of people
will be offered the scheme but again it
is not at all clear
how one gets that offer or why michael
gove who is a ministering cabinet
got offered that scheme as opposed to
why somebody else would it raises
questions and i think those questions
grow louder when you look at the
behavior
of other ministers as well especially
around travel
so it has been an extraordinary fact of
the third lockdown that for months at a
time
it was actually illegal to leave the
country your passport would not get you
out
of the country you had to fit very
specific and strict requirement
to be able to legally leave but there
were exemptions for ministers
not just travel exemptions but
quarantine and testing exemptions
as well now you can think of lots of
good reasons why government officials
might need to travel abroad even in a
pandemic national security reasons
potentially i think there's an argument
for liz trust the trade secretary
you know we've just left the european
union she's trying to secure trade deals
i think you can just
about argue it but why was wendy morton
one of the foreign ministers in greece
in march
when people couldn't even sit on a park
bench together touring greece
touring the ancient architecture to talk
about climate change
why was greg hans throughout the winter
going to slovenia
and croatia tweeting about how he was
delighted to be back where he took
his honeymoon so that he could be
talking about business and tech i think
it becomes really
difficult to argue that those are
necessary
essential trips when people can't
legally leave the country it would be
one thing perhaps
if we had actually opened up on the 21st
of june i think there would be less
scrutiny over this
if they had returned our freedoms but
we're now seeing photos of michael gove
matt hancock the health secretary nadim
zawahi the vaccine minister
at the football multiple of them in vip
sections enjoying themselves kicking
back relaxing
well we're still told that seven people
cannot legally gather together
in your private home you know these
ministers have put in a lot of hard work
the vaccine rollout's been a huge
success i don't blame them for wanting
to take a break
but it's the inconsistency and the
different parallel
lifestyles that's problematic it's fine
for them to go to the football
but is it not fine for us to watch in
our homes together and have a beer and
enjoy each other's company
but kate here is one answer it's always
been the case
that senior politicians have been able
to be blue lighted across the traffic if
they need to be
given various tips and perks to speed up
their life because
they are acting on behalf of the people
that's the argument
not just in the old soviet union but
here in democracies that if you're at
the top of governments your time needs
to be precious you need a greater
license to operate because a lot of
people are counting on you being able to
do your
job well so surely what we're seeing
with the
with loopholes you're talking about it's
just simply a more vivid extension of
what happens in
any healthy democracy is that and steps
are taken to let politicians and
ministers
go about their job as quickly as
possible for the sake of us all
we're well aware that if you're in a
position of power you're always going to
be able to bend the
rules just that little bit more right i
think that's widely
acknowledged but these are very
different circumstances
our liberties have been taken away we
have been told to stay home we have been
legally required to stay in the country
you are breaking the law
if you have more than five friends six
friends whatever your household size is
into your home you know you could be
slapped with a fine worth
thousands and thousands of pounds and if
dominic rob the foreign secretary needs
to go
abroad for some reason for national
security purposes that's quite an
easy argument to make but the idea that
our day-to-day lives are any less
essential
or less important than a minister who's
in croatia
talking about business and tech or alex
shama
who's president of cop 26 in march going
to france going to kenya
going to costa rica to talk about a
conference that's taking place in
glasgow
and not opting for zoom and instead
opting to fly around the world during a
pandemic which we're told is far too
dangerous for us to do
isn't a matter of working in the
public's interest it's just simply
not fair kate andrews thanks very much
indeed
now if you subscribe to the spectator
you'll have read about these stories but
if you don't then maybe you'd like to
give us a try we're offering four weeks
free on spectator
dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer i'd argue that life is too short
to not
read the spectator but then again i'm
biased
now have white working-class kids being
left behind in our education system
a report from a select committee in
parliament this week says that poor
white boys
perform worse than almost every other
group at every level of education
robert halfriend who chairs the
committee joins me now along with morris
macleod who's the chief exec
of race on the agenda an anti-racism
campaign group
now robert halford let's start with you
you took a question from nick gibb
during your inquiry
and he told you straight out that race
isn't a factor
it's poverty that holds people back so
have you guys been barking up the wrong
tree all along
well i massive respect for nick gibb um
i
approve what he's done to try and
improve standards
i think that his work on phonics and
literacy
is incredibly important but i have a
fundamental disagree with him and i
think his answer
was part of the muddled thinking that
has gone on for decades in response to
this problem we know that there are
900 000 plus white working class
uh pupils from disadvantaged backgrounds
on free school
meals we know that at every stage of the
education system
they underperform almost every other
ethnic group you know just 17.7 percent
get good passes at gcse maths and
english and just 16
go to university and that's lower than
afro-caribbean and
other ethnic ethnic groups so the stock
answer to this has always been
uh it's muddled and it's in some ways
lazy thinking
is that it is due to poverty and what is
needed is more of the same
uh policies from the department if it
was down to poverty
of course that's a factor why on earth
are other ethnic
communities for the most part performing
much better than disadvantaged white
working class
pupils and often the poverty levels of
those ethnic communities are even worse
than disadvantaged white communities
maurice mcleod your chief exec of race
on the agenda do you think it's right
that race
should be at the forefront of this
particular agenda when we're trying to
work out why
some kids do worse than others and we
should look at white working class as a
discrete group
yeah i think it's it's it's interesting
when i saw
this report was coming out um there have
been a number
it feels of reports into white
working-class
kids and they're under achievement um to
my mind the the issue
with and it's it's it's right to
highlight that this this group
the group that are on free school meals
which isn't the same as saying
uh working class by the way sixty
percent of people consider themselves
working class but i think
uh sort of like fifteen or seventeen
percent of of kids are actually on free
school meals so that's
it's not it doesn't matter quite as as
clearly as
as maybe the headlines are pretending
but they're
to my mind they're not disadvantaged
because of their race that's
that's why i i find the the framing
maybe of this this work slightly um
confusing
right and robert halford that's quite a
good point isn't it i mean you looked at
sam the phrase white privilege in your
report and you said you didn't think it
was a helpful
term but if you use language like this
that was quite
explosive several members of your
committee walked out
but you also say that even the
terminology isn't quite there
as maurice mcleod says we're not really
talking about white working class new
report you look at kids on free school
meals
now sure they that's a subsection of the
working class but
there isn't even language here for what
you're you're grasping not just for
answers but you're grasping for
basic vocabulary yeah the first point is
we make it very clear in the report the
data set we're looking at and we're
looking
at a white working class boys and girls
on freeschool meals from disadvantaged
backgrounds and we explained that
in the in in the report of course there
is a generic term for white working
class but
that is the group that we are looking at
that underperform
as i say against almost every other
ethnic group now on the point of white
privilege
and the reason why we put this in report
the labour members didn't walk out they
just voted against the
report but the reason why we put it in
because it's wrong fundamentally wrong
for three reasons
so the first reason is that if you use
the concept of white privilege you are
implying
collective guilt when it should be
individual responsibility for acts of
racism and the second reason is
if you use the word white privilege
you're basically telling
a poor a white community that they are
privileged you're telling a single
parent who might live in a tiny flat in
my constituency of harlow
doing their best to bring up their child
that they have white privilege and the
third reason is that it's factually
incorrect because all the data shows
that
far from being privileged in education
uh
these disadvantaged white communities
are doing worse as a repeat than almost
any other ethnic group and i just
want to add that i'm not this is you
know people go on about the culture wars
if you walk along the streets of my
constituency no one would even know what
the culture wars
are about i am uh raising this my
committee has raised this because what
all the people here and you can make an
intellectual argument about what right
with privilege means
but i'm a wrong seal type politician
white privilege does what it says on the
tin it just tells people whatever their
background whatever their circumstances
that they have white privilege those are
the only two words
that they that they hear and it's wrong
it's being introduced by councils it's
being recommended by educational
uh groups it's got to stop uh spreading
it is not the way to deal with racism
maurice mccloud you must have some
sympathy with that i mean is white
privilege
a problematic does it does the very
phrase
tell somebody in the council state who's
had no privilege at all in their life
but they're inherently well off just
because of the color of their skin as
a form of racism isn't it yeah so so i
think the
the white privilege thing to me it's a
bit of a red herring i think that
that's um you know getting obsessed on
whether that term
uh translates well with a certain
audience isn't
isn't really the thing i i i don't think
so so
um yes you know arguing to someone
that's that's
really deprived that's that's that's all
seen all economy economics or benefit go
a different direction and telling
that person they've got privilege seems
like a a a hard thing to say but you
wouldn't
find any difficulty telling someone
who's poor and
you know was really struggling yes
you're already poor but
aren't you better off than someone who
had who's disabled for instance that
they can they can understand that link
and i think that sometimes when we have
these sorts of conversations
um so if you're talking about uh for
instance the kids on free school meals
which is what we're talking about white
kids on free school meals
and you compare them to black kids on
free school meals and say look they're
they're they're achieving even worse
isn't that terrible this shows that
that it's because they're white and
they're being you know they're being
disadvantaged
well surely the the the geography of
where people are
as as i think it says in the report
place matters now if you're comparing
you know kids in the north in a deprived
area with
uh black kids in london who yes i have
equal levels of poverty or sometimes
even more poverty
but have other resources around them
because they happen to live in the south
where all of the
wealth has been extracted to you're not
comparing like with like
so so robert your your problem then is
that
you know you've got the debater but you
want to talk about the white working
class even that phrase is problematic
you talk about white privilege
it's so incendiary that you've got um
members of your committee who don't vote
with the report
and then if you read the report i have
to say i couldn't find very much in the
way of solutions from it
at the end and i think the um it seems
that there's a quote
i think from the from the new schools
network of center for social justice
saying that there were basic there was
no national solution
to this problem so aren't you really on
a hiding to nothing here you're you're
sort of
going going into this sort of culture
warsy territory but to no real avail
well i think i think um
with respect massive respect to you
fraser that's wrong on all counts
because they were the report is full of
full of solutions to deal with this
problem i mean the pro the issue is that
um first of all in terms of even
discussing um the under performance of
white working class boys and girls it's
seen as a taboo issue and it isn't that
loads of people discussing whenever it's
raised you get a huge amount of
criticism we should be able to debate
things like
the terminology of white privilege
without being shouted down
or without being described as i have
been by the neu as dr shipman
uh today or representative from the neu
we have to debate and discuss these
things
otherwise you just close down debate and
one side has all the
arguments to some extent you're not
tilting your windmills a little bit here
i mean however as you say
go into the streets people don't use
language like culture wars how often do
they come across
the language the problem is that it's
being the concept of white privilege as
being
recommended and introduced in our
education system recommended by
educational groups recommended by
uh councils and we've got examples of
that in the report but in terms of the
solutions again
that is wrong the report is full of
solutions changing the
what's happened often is that money has
been thrown at big cities so we had the
london challenge which has improved
london
schools but towns have been left behind
we recommend to
target much better the pupil premium so
that you target it down to
target funding down to at neighborhood
level where disadvantaged communities
live
we recommend that family hubs should be
put around in every town across the
country because early years intervention
makes a difference we've looked at the
what the felt and reach academy
do and suggest parental engagement
programs where parents have been
disengaged from
the curriculum and education from one
generation to the next
and it does work because we've seen
examples of it from felt
reach we've suggested solutions in terms
of increasing the vocational elements of
the curriculum perhaps
having design and technology in the
bacchloria getting teachers to
disadvantaged areas by introducing
teaching degree apprenticeships and
bursaries and financial incentives and
training colleges or training providers
for those teachers in disadvantaged
areas we've suggested
adult community learning centers in
every town again
to re-engage uh parents we've looked at
the university access fund
800 million that's spent to try and get
disadvantaged pupils which
is not working to university it's not
working at all and suggested that there
should be
targe proper targets from the office of
students to get more
white to disadvantaged students into
university but also
using it to fund more degree
apprenticeships so these pupils can earn
while they learn not worry about taking
on debt
get a skill and get a job at the end so
all the way through the report
it is lined with explanation and aligned
with with solutions and the white
privilege argument is literally two or
three pages
out of a a 90-page report so the report
is full of solutions you may not agree
with them
that is that is your right but it is
wrong to say that this is just a report
or imply that it's just a report about
the cultural uh whatever you call want
to call it the cultural battle cultural
wars
uh morris one of the things that does
come through from the report
is the limitations even when you're
talking about bain for example that's a
generalization
but even black is a generalization
because the outcomes of black africans
are seem to be significantly worse and
the
better story than for black caribbeans
and major parts the education system
the same is true if you talk about south
asians the outcomes for indians tend to
be a lot better than whites
for pakistani and bangladeshi
backgrounds a lot worse
so isn't there a lot more nuance here
than ever label being
or even south asian and black are these
labels starting to
to conceal more than they reveal
um i'm not sure that they're sick
concealing more than they reveal i do
think there's a problem
with uh labels it's one of the things
that is one of the things that the cred
report
pointed to which i think was it was kind
of a right to point out that the bain
sort of label lumps everyone in together
and there are so many different uh
experiences uh that different groups
have so i think i think it's worth
worth pointing out i do i do think that
i don't think that that should be used
to say okay so it's all too complicated
let's just not look at it at all or
let's you know we do need to drill down
into individual communities we do need
to drill down and look at
the gypsy roma traveler communities and
work out why
they they are often achieving so much
lower
than almost any other group these things
do matter and they do they are connected
to
to culture and to race and things like
that so what about what white working
class though i mean do you accept
there's a problem there because if you
look at them
you'll see these league tables white
working class are the group least likely
to get into university in this country
more than any other ethnic group
there are studies after studies which
show white white boys specifically white
working-class boys
as being the bottom of this pile so if
you care
about inequality i mean i've known you
for 20 years and you've always
been going on you've always been on the
side of those
and facing the the strongest headwinds
isn't there a case to say for whatever
reason
white working-class boys are facing
incredibly strong headwinds
in this country they may be in the
ethnic majority but they're really
facing problems and if we care about
those problems we simply have
to have these conversations no matter
how uncomfortable they might be
absolutely no you absolutely have to
have the conversation but
what i'm i guess challenging is that is
is
that i don't think that this part of the
conversation needs to be racialized if
you're talking about working class
children and what they need and how they
need to be how their educational
uh standards needs to be lifted up and
how they've been sort of neglected for
for decades let's be honest
um nothing in the in the stuff that
robert just said
uh um you know in in the tools that are
in the
in the solutions that are in this report
none of them are specific to white
people i'm not really
sure why why label this as you know the
report into fixing
that they will they will both benefit
both they will benefit all disadvantaged
communities but they will also address
the problems
that disadvantaged white communities
face and
and also we're we're focusing a lot on
towns because if you look at the maps in
the report that is where
predominantly white working class
communities live and previously as i say
all the funds all the policy reform has
primarily be based
being based looking after the big cities
and the london challenge
which has improved london schools has
been a big example of that
a bit more to two points about poverty
though i mean if you look at for example
at chinese pupils and free school meals
their outcomes educationally are better
than
than rich whites so you can't say that
or if if your analysis was true then
surely everybody in free school meals
would have the same outcome
and in fact what this report shows is
the huge differentials and outcomes for
work for free school meal pupils
depending on their ethnicity
yeah i'm not at all arguing that i think
they're they're
when when we're talking about the white
working class kids in particular
i think there's more i don't i still
haven't heard any
explanation for why how their ethnicity
is part of
the challenge for them i think it's more
to do with the geography it's more to do
where
where they live in the country well
that's exactly what we said though if
you read the report that's exactly what
we've said and
and going back to the white privilege
argument it's other people who want to
turn into an ethnicity
um by accusing people of being white
privileged who are not
um which is why we put those few pages
in the report about
it to try actually make this argument
that it is about place and it's about
a class and where people live and
there's regional equalities family
disengagement from
the curriculum multi-generational
disadvantage
and lack of attention paid to the fact
that these students don't go to
a university lack of attention paid to
the cultural
often cultural factors which in white
communities they want more vocational
education and apprentices can we talk a
bit more about that
which was quite interesting the cultural
aspects i mean you have heard it argued
that if you take two kids of three
school meals say you you've got a son of
take sergeant javid for example with
some of indian immigrants now they came
to this country mainly so their son
could avail himself
or the education system there his mom
took him from school to the library she
made him stay there until six o'clock
to learn and sasha javis and his brother
baz is now a commander
in the metropolitan police are great
examples of the british dream
but it said look that is in any way a
quite well
well understood immigrant story but
compare that to white working class
culture where you've got parents
who will have had a very different
experience perhaps of the education
system
it was not obvious to them that working
hard at school particularly paid
dividends in life so they're not going
to prioritize it
as parents and so perhaps that culture
could be something that's very difficult
that's exactly like what sounds as if
you're talking down
but no we actually got uh we've actually
looked at this
in the in the report you're exactly
right and we make the point as funny
enough the
the commission for race disparity also
made the point that often new immigrant
families coming in
that they see education as a root out of
poverty and my father was an immigrant
to this country he worked day and night
i actually got sent to a private school
my father came here with nothing but
work day night because his
view was education was everything and
that would be
a you know mean we would have success
success in life what has happened with
many disadvantaged white communities
is for one reason and another they were
let down in previous generations often
by the education system or became
disengaged from it
they became just and they passed that on
from one generation to the next that
that disengagement and that's why we've
talked about family hubs and parental
engagement programs and looked at the
remarkable work of felt reach academy
and others
and see see whether or not it can be
replicated to re-engage those families
into the education system so we don't
kind of perpetuate this for
you know this kind of disengagement for
infinity and
you know so this is why this report is
about a lot more than just
two the two words of what of white white
privilege although nevertheless it is an
important subject as i say to be debated
on morris mccloud that's an interesting
point isn't it
i mean clean color aside you do have an
issue here
of white working-class parents who would
have been hit by perhaps the
industrialization in the 80s
who would have whose grandparents might
have come from a culture as my dad was
when you basically left school at 15
that's what you did
nobody expected it to be any different
so it's not so much skin color it's more
culture it's what your parents
experience is what they expect it's what
your grandparents expected
and that is simply different for the
children of
white working class than it is i don't
know perhaps for the
for the young children of immigrants
like sacha javi's parents who would have
come here thinking to themselves
this this school is going to be the
ladder from my son all the way up
what white working class might not have
the same perspective or historical
experience
yeah i i'm sure that um uh uh
intergenerational memory and all that
sort of stuff comes into it i mean you
know none of this all this stuff is
nuanced so
so i don't think you can just look at um
um just say okay these ingredients came
in and they did well
therefore therefore there's not a
problem with the system now it might be
that they're
you don't you're not comparing light for
light necessarily if you i know a lot of
um
my friends whose families came from
africa were asian but families came from
africa
uh during the sort of 80s and 70s they
didn't come in
poor they didn't come to this country in
the same way that that maybe
my mum when she came over from jamaica
came over she wasn't dirt poor but she
didn't come over
with with with any amount of wealth she
came over to
to sort of start at the bottom and work
so there's a different yeah
yeah comparing those two outlooks and
those two
uh ways of bringing up children
obviously uh comes into it but you can't
i don't think you can ignore
the the racialized nature of
of existence especially for people from
minority
ethnic communities in britain that that
is something that follows through and if
you're looking if you're saying
uh um uh parents aren't instilling the
value of education in their kids
kids aren't stupid they they look and
they see their big brothers and people
from a few years older than them
who've gone through education who've
done you know done all the right things
and aren't and still aren't getting on
so you you need to
to take into account you know what
what's the actual offer
with education what what are you what
are you being promised robert half from
the morris mcleod
thanks very much indeed now the
manchester bombing inquiry reported
earlier this week douglas murley has
written this column about it
this week and he joins me now douglas
you've been following this for quite
some time
what jumped out at you in this report
well we learned a number of things uh
the inquiry finds uh the number of
occasions
on which uh salman abedi the
suicide bomber in question on the night
of the ariana grande concert in 2017
the inquiry finds a number of occasions
when he could have been identified and
should have been identified
could have been stopped and should have
been stopped
now inquiries like this seems to me
having read a lot of them in my time
always are going to find
faults it's inevitable there will be
intelligence
faults there will be security faults
human error
and more and and and this is no
different to that extent
uh there's human error of a staggering
kind
the most obvious being uh two uh um
members of the police who went for a
kebab half an hour away
uh when they were meant to be at the
venue and then ate their dinner
in a secure room and
basically weren't doing their job uh
there were things like that but as i say
in my column this week the
really disturbing thing about this
inquiry
by sir john saunders is something that
is revealed
by a single witness who worked for one
of the security companies
at the manchester arena on the night
and can you tell us a bit more about
this is kyle lawler the
who is at the time 18 year old security
guard paid four pounds 26 per hour
yeah um i mean there's something should
be said about this by the way which is
before
he said which is you know these security
companies as we know from previous
incidents they had a sort of veneer of
security
but basically if anything serious
happens uh
most of the time these companies are not
fit for purpose
uh so they add a sort of feeling of
security without actually providing it
and what i'm about to say as i say in
the piece i don't know criticize
mr lawler for this he was a young man
and
i can't imagine what he has on his
conscience in relation to this but he
was at least
honest to the inquiry uh kyle lawler
says that like a number of other people
on the night
he noticed salman abedi he couldn't have
failed to notice him in a way because
salman abadi was hanging around
for more than an hour and a quarter by
the entrance exits
of the building he was inside the
building he was struggling
with a 32 kilogram rucksack
which we now know contained the bomb
and kyle lawler was one of the people on
the night who
noticed him thought there was something
up and he says
specifically that what he noticed about
mr a baby going backwards and forward
struggling with his
extremely heavy uh backpack was he said
he had a nervous reaction uh whenever
anyone looked at him
and seemed fidgety now
that's uh not the important thing the
important thing is what kyle lawler said
after this he stated to the inquiry
that he was fearful of identifying mr
abadi
he said he was fearful of being branded
a racist
and feared that he would be in trouble
if he got it wrong
and as i say in my piece
one shouldn't blame kyle lawler first it
is
perhaps inevitable some people would but
i admire the fact he was honest about
it he was honest about the fact that
actually in modern britain
quite understandably he made the
decision
that if you see something you shouldn't
say something you should shut up
because there's far more to risk by
saying something and being accused of
being a racist
than there is of not saying something
and the bomb going off
that's a calibration that modern britain
has
indoctrinated people into for many many
years
and you can't just indoctrinate people
out of it
when i was reading the report i was
really quite struck by the kind of
strength of character that carl lawler
must
have i mean i'm not sure in his
situation he was somebody who i think
learned his trade via an online course
so
he had been given very little training
no real experience
yet it would have been very easy for him
just to pretend that he'd seen
nothing to not have anybody publicly
blame him for missing something because
i'm sure some people will say well if
only he'd blown the whistle
of course he's putting himself up there
for criticism
i imagine though he's doing this to make
a rather important point
that a lot of people in his position
would hesitate
to blow the whistle for the reasons that
he gives that
you might be branded discriminatory and
i guess the same is true for anybody
who's in the security industry because
when you stop somebody who looks
suspicious
i guess you do need to ask yourself am i
being biased here to what extent
is racial profiling morally acceptable
when it comes to stopping people going
through airports through other
shopping another this is a dilemma we've
had ever since 9-1-1
that's right in fact of course as you
know and we have an entire industry now
in britain as across the rest of the
western world
which says that we've not just got
biases but they're inbuilt in us they're
implicit in us
and we have to eradicate them we have to
question our alleged biases
we've got to do double takes all the
time
mentally this is a whole industry that
the
the vast swathes of government the
private sector and others have imbibed
and this isn't the reason why salman
obedient got into it
that's just one further manifestation of
the problem
that kyle lawler has so sadly put his
finger on
as you say you know fraser you know this
is a young guy
who underwent very little training he
said that he had no particular knowledge
there was going to be an incident on the
night which is true he couldn't have
known that
he could have known they should have
been told that the terrorism threat in
the uk was severe at the time it was
only shortly
after the attack in westminster uh
before of course the attack on london
bridge but the the
the terrorism uh risk status was at
severe but again it's people
much more senior than this very
junior online trained security officer
who i think have to take some
responsibility
for getting britain into the position
that you can't honestly identify
somebody who you think might be a
suicide bomber for fear
of basically detonating your own career
and i mentioned in my piece several
examples of high
profile police officers in greater
manchester
who set the scene for that because as i
mentioned in the piece
one year almost exactly before the
manchester arena bombing
there was a test
exercise at the manchester shopping
center
in which the local um security services
the local
emergency services trained for basically
an eventuality uncannily like the one on
the night in the manchester arena
it was to test the preparedness of the
first responders of the emergency
services
and the whole occasion was marred by a
single detail
which is that the actor playing the
suicide bomber on that occasion
at the manchester shopping center
shouted allahu akbar
or allah is greatest before detonating
the
fake device that then led to the play
act and the
attempt to prepare the emergency
services the whole
exercise was um forgotten about
and massively marred by this
fact because there was an immediate
backlash against
the uh whole scenario for the person
playing the suicide bomber
shouting allahu akbar and therefore
totally appallingly outrageously
unforgivably
linking the possibility of a suicide
bombing
with islamist extremism and all
of the local community leaders went off
on this how dare you make this
connection and the local police people
like the
greater manchester police and crime
commissioner tony lloyd all
apologized for it they said it's
outrageous it's it's
marred and otherwise successful event
and
i think uh tony lloyd the greater
manchester police and crime commissioner
said
that this didn't add anything to the
event
the shouting of allah it just has the
potential he said
to undermine the great community
relations we have
in greater manchester so this is the
position that people like
kyle lawler found themselves on the
night that there was a real-time suicide
bomber
really standing in front of them under
their noses struggling with a 32
kilogram bomb
they had been told by every major
policeman in the area
that you should do nothing to link these
things
and that is why we had effectively
trained people
trained people out of identifying what
was under their noses
right at the time as you say douglas the
threat level was
number three and but it's right now it's
number two
substantial it seems in the last 20
years there's hardly been many times
where there hasn't been
a kind of a threat and yet so so you can
understand why the security guard we
didn't quite know what
they wouldn't have been really expecting
one of these attacks but you also have
to work
wonder just how much you can really
expect
out of relatively junior people who were
i mean you know you could see probably
somebody seen you perhaps a soldier or
something might be able to
to work that thing out but even the
metropolitan police have had lots of
problems stop and search
they've been accused of racially
profiling black londoners theresa may
told them to stop it and it can be a
very difficult balance
to to get right because if you you go
too much and of course you end up
with a system where people of asian or
middle eastern outlook get asked for
their id even in the house of commons
here a lot more than
than white so you can see why there is
concern
of of taking this a bit too far in
certain circumstances
well what happens here is that the
balance swings
too far in one direction and
we have to accept the fact that in 2017
uh the profile of a
suicide bomber at a pop concert
pretty much exactly fitted the profile
of salman abadi
a young radicalized male
of north african or middle eastern uh
descent
this was pretty much the likely
person it was not a woman it was not a
white woman
uh it was a particular profile
and you might say well you know
you've got to check 20 people who don't
fit the profile
in order to allow yourself to check one
person who does fit the profile
but as we saw on the night in manchester
these sorts of games are ones you can
treat yourself
to until it gets really serious and the
manchester arena bombing was
an unbelievable event and it should
never be forgotten it's been
to some extent i've always said slightly
brushed over i have to say
when you consider the amount of
attention that some
outrages get the extraordinary way in
which it's sort of been
you know rushed over almost from the
beginning we had the whole don't look
back in
anger sort of thing about it this whole
don't draw any lessons out from it and
by the way there are still lessons we
don't know we just don't know answers to
very major questions even after the
saunders report i
i give an example in my column this week
of something we still don't know
salman a baby's parents came to the uk
in the 1990s the father was a member of
the libyan islamic fighting group which
uh subsequently joined al qaeda
uh joined up with al-qaeda as an
affiliate the father of salman abedi
was in the libyan islamic fighting group
and they fell out with colonel gaddafi
in the 1990s very sadly
uh these people fell out with each other
and so britain
gave sanctuary to the baby parents and
that's how young salman abedi was born
in the uk he was born because we gave
his
parents asylum and uh salman abadi
and his utterly reprehensible brother
uh um were the gifts we got in britain
for this i still can't find
after all this time and even after this
review any explanation from any official
in the uk as to why this happened
why did we give them asylum what did we
gain
from it what exactly other than two
appalling sons
did they give to this country or bring
to this country
nothing nada zilch and yet
nobody in authority has ever yet
given an explanation for this let alone
been held accountable for this
and this is one of the things i still
find absolutely astonishing in the
british discussion of this
we always get in the uk as i've written
its spectator many times
we always get these sort of slightly
fake debates you know
to my mind stop and search is a
relatively comfortable
debate compared to some of the other
debates that we ought to have
why was it that the obedie family were
in the uk
why was it that in the london bridge
attack only weeks later
two of the three attackers had as far as
i can understand
no legitimate cause for being in the uk
one who lied about his nationality was
found out to have lied and then anyway
wasn't
deported from the uk and the other was
somebody who claimed asylum from
pakistan
a few years ago why was the uk giving
asylum to somebody from pakistan in the
late 1990s or early 2000s
why was it that when somebody pretends
to be a moroccan turns out to be a
libyan
hacks at women's throats on london
bridge while shouting
that nobody's much interested in what
he's doing here in the first place
and all the crappy security supremos get
on to the comfortable debates they get
onto things like oh
to what extent is online radicalization
an issue because it's so much easier to
talk about these crappy
third-rate issues of what you can do
with google and
and so on it's so much easier than just
those
basic elementary questions there has
never been an asking of those elementary
questions
there still hasn't been and i think it
points
to the failures we still have even after
all these years in the uk
of properly discussing what is a serious
security threat that's ongoing but one
potential answer there
is that we we gave him i don't know the
details but at the time colonel gaddafi
wasn't exactly running a benign regime
you could certainly see why
um somebody might be fleeing in fear of
their life from that regime unlike most
european countries
you can definitely see that you can
definitely see that so that's what you
want
in the country that that question is
relatively easy to answer
that that question should be relatively
easy to answer but there will be
probably thousands of other libyan
refugees who've led
constructive lives into the country i'm
not at all sure
that the british taxpayers money
is well spent in giving asylum
to jihadists who've fallen out with
other jihadists
i mean it's possible we could decide to
be the great uh
convening center some people would argue
we have been in recent decades
for the sort of you know intra-jihadist
fallout community um but i don't think
that's what the british
public ever wanted i know it's something
we were never asked about
uh so so so yes there are explanations
and i'd like to hear them and i'd like
them to be stressed by the officials i'd
like them to justify their
decisions i'd like them to explain to
the british public
why it seems there are so many cases of
people who've gone on to commit
terrorist acts
who as far as i can see gave britain
nothing
and took in the case of salman abadi 22
young lives
douglas murley thanks very much for
joining us on spectator tv
now remember you can get a trial
subscription to the spectator and a 20
pound
amazon voucher for just 12 pounds on
dot co dot uk forward slash tv offer
you'll be able to read douglas's column
and all the other latest from our
contributors and columnists
our leader book review this week is
about a new biography of william hogarth
perhaps
one of britain's greatest satirists who
has inspired generations of cartoonists
coming after him
including our own michael keith who's
been the spectator's
cartoon editor for three decades michael
i'm delighted that you can join us now
on spectator tv so
tell us uh are you one of these
cartoonists who
has an intellectual debt to hogarth um
well beyond me total genius amazing
obviously if i'm looking around him and
seeing what's going on in a
terrible city and almost people dying
and drinking and women
being naughty something that you
couldn't possibly do nowadays he would
be
counted or clouted or whatever the word
is cancelled
he wouldn't be allowed to work and
anyway we have to i
do work about 10 minutes or 20 minutes
that's the way it is now you give me the
size and i fill it up but
to be allowed to even talk about hogarth
or touch his hem
is almost too much for me
well michael you've been um doing
fantastic stuff for the spectator
for well longer than i've been alive
and you just get better i'd like to say
okay and thank you
can you tell us now about that what you
have done you're
you're observing not just politics but
society as well themes
certain types of people we we have it in
your battle of britain colin
can you tell us a bit about the trends
that you see now and
what you're trying to depict okay right
when i started 1952
55 something like that i think i had my
first drawing the spectator in 1957.
um hitler playing the guitar from memory
oh no i'm not sure you get away with
that nowadays
i can remember the clothes i put on them
the interesting thing is that in those
days
you could tell men from women and you
could tell
what jobs people have a banker would
come along with a bowler hat and a
cane and all the rest of it an umbrella
and you knew where you were there's a
butcher and you
dressed in as a butcher nowadays you
don't know where you are and you can't
point people out by drawing them and the
way they are so our students or whoever
i'm all dressed exactly the same so if
they've just been woken up
and um put some clothes on and i think
against them i do love them nearly
but um it's a totally different time
from now
i'm in total um admiration for this man
i guess and i should imagine he took the
drink at some point and then i think he
gave it out became very religious but
still we get quite a lot
our mailbag is normally pretty full
every week
of aspiring cartoonists sending in their
work to see if they manage to
to catch your eyes so what advice would
you have for somebody wanting to submit
to cartoon to you
right now what do you think makes a
makes a good cartoon need publishing a
spectator
i am asked quite a bit about this and uh
unfortunately things happen and they
don't
they don't know how to do it and they
don't know how to do it to such speed
and um they don't take rejection uh my
half of my stuff is projected uh i do
rafts and they're not used and that's it
and they choose one so much the better
if you use me
and i turn it around very quickly i love
that but it's i
i can't say young person it's awful but
as someone trying to do
a cartoon they will not accept rejection
which you get all the time and they
do things and they think they're very
good and then they send them into an
editor or whatever it is and they get
rejected and they say well i'm not doing
that again you know i mean
whereas i just plowed on and as to where
i was that was
words i'd use for it i can't use even on
your
television program but i did some i was
driven to do it because i'd
been shown the new yorker of all things
about 1947 and now it's as funny as
nothing it's hopeless uh but it was very
funny then and i liked
and got energy from american humor in
those days
now and that sort of gone uh that
vanishes
anyway i um sent a drawing to new york
magazine in 1958
i think i thought they might buy that
and they did send a letter back and they
said um
i'm afraid we'd like you to alter it a
bit and change it otherwise we'll take
it so i changed it a bit a little bit
and you send it back and then they say
could you do this and do that and
take the foreground out and put the
background in and then change the men to
women and so you get fed up with it you
don't want to do any more
either way they paid you 500 which you
could do quite a bit with that then
recently i was asked to buy the new york
or someone at the new yorker who said to
me could i
show my droids there can i show them
roughs every
thursday or friday from here the
spectator
and email them to the new yorker and i
said that's good ideas very nice i do
that i did that
and it came back i mean that's finally
rejected me
and i did this every week for a year and
they sent back
the same ones kept on rejecting
everything i ever did
so i mean and that's me doing it i'm
imagining someone was starting out doing
it
and now they draw i don't know how they
get artists there aren't
artists in the new yorker magazine but
they're drawings of some sort but
they're not funny
funny's out not with me
yeah i might how much do you think you
can learn about a country's politics or
society from cartoons if you were to
pick up a spectator not read a word
but just look at the cartoons how much
could you really glean about what was
going on well
you you i think you'd learn a lot by
reading the spectator for the last 20
years or 40 years or whatever it is
or longer than that i i love it because
of that
i love it because it's um
interesting witty and does all sorts of
things that
magazines should do which don't and
that's just the cartoons of course
well yes the cartoons as well as the
writing for god's sake
um it's like a pudding and everything's
in it the drawings are in it and then
the
articles are in it and the reviews are
in it and it's something you want to
read
desperately and i run around trying to
get it on thursday mornings where i live
and it's not easy to get that way but i
mean i'm
obsessed with the damn thing but michael
when you're trying to get ideas for
cartoons you must have to read a lot
observe a lot i mean you know can you
just sit in your bedroom and have ideas
come for you if you're going to be
commenting as you're doing the spectator
and in the mail on sunday
about what's going on you need a
depiction a line
a sort of insight into a political
situation current affairs there must be
quite a lot of work
and research that you do before the gag
comes to you well yes you have to keep
your eye on the papers
um and the daily mail and all the rest
of it
um and you have to find out what's going
on or what's not going on or what
they're
moaning and screaming about and all the
rest of it the trouble is you can do a
drawing one day because things are so
quick
everyone forgets about it the following
day when they see it um
i don't i don't know of anyone that's
coming up or
any person or young person or even an
old person who wants to do it or can't
do it
at the speed and and make as you say
a political statement it we make a
statement about
our lives and the way life is and the
way things are seemed and all the rest
of it
but i think it's now too everything's
too neurotically quick
fast and furious and there's not much
just get it down on paper and see what
happens and then the only way to make a
living i mean i
used to go from magazine to magazine to
magazine and you go in and show them the
stuff like touch your forelock
governor and they look at it and then
you might say go away and don't come
back or
love to see you again that's what
happened here and i was
on two pounds two shillings a week you
buy a house for that then
michael heath it's a great pleasure to
speak to you as always and there's even
special
pleasure to have you debut on spectator
tv that's it for this week
i hope you enjoyed the episode do pick
up the magazine to read
a lot more along these lines and a
special thank you to
cindy you our producer
[Music]
you